[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting the lights a little bit
brighter because the excitement's a
little bit bigger because yeah our book
is if you're listening on the audio
version it's just about to come out
tomorrow October 29th here watching the
video version this thing's been out by
this thing um you know by this thing
give it to people wait here
we're so excited because we've it's such
a big project for us and this is such a
big culmination thank you for listening
to this right now and I did we just want
to make this a shared experience of
celebration a milestone of we made this
thing and it it's a big thing it's a
freaking novel and we're gonna be
talking a lot of freaking work how long
we've been working on this thing I'd say
the the inception goes back two years
two year and again we work on so many
things that don't take that much time
that take you know a day and then a
couple of days later it's on the
internet and this is because it is
simultaneously very personal which we'll
get into today but also very much one of
our most if not the most creatively
ambitious thing that we've ever done it
brings those two things together in a
way that is just it's just energized us
so this week at the roundtable of dim
lighting we're going to be exploring how
our childhood informed the novel and the
way we're gonna do that is we're
actually gonna read some of the novel
and I want to say and then just no
spoilers no spoilers we yeah I say
generally spoiler-free I mean no it's
it's it's a completely spoiler free in
the name of light traditional spoilers
like you're not gonna spoil any of the
story the plot I'm very comfortable
saying it spoiler free I mean one and
you're a spoiler stickler oh yeah once
we picked out the
the excerpts that we're gonna read I
went through and marked out the things
that I considered spoilers and I have a
very very low tolerance for spoilers I
mean I'm surprised you even let people
see the book I mean that's how crazy you
can get it but I don't if I know I'm
gonna watch a movie I do not watch the
trailer I do not all I want to know from
people if they seen a movie I want to
see is good do you recommend that I see
it or not and you just say yes or no
that's all I don't want you to tell me
anything else it was like yeah but don't
so you can you can listen easy we're not
gonna what we're gonna introduce you to
some of the characters and we are gonna
skip around the book if you yeah if
you're if you're if you're looking at
the video version you know we'll say
tabs those of you who depending on when
you're listening to this are coming to
the Bleak Creek conversations if you
listen to this right when it comes out
on the audio version you can still go
see us in New York tonight
and then you know the rest of the week
will be in different places bleak recom
rhettandlink live.com you can find out
about that we're gonna I'm also gonna be
on Fallon gonna be on Fallon tonight's
show we're going to be reading
distinctly different passages that we
will get to in bleak read conversations
and of course conversations it's kind of
a totally different thing we're gonna be
showing the documentary and all that so
you can enjoy both of these we've taken
pains to make sure that they're
different and we're discussing different
things
tadam yeah you know what let's get into
it let's let's read the prologue you do
the honors and we'll go back and forth
on different excerpts okay why don't you
just break into this prologue read that
and then we'll kind of set up more of I
don't know just the just our our general
approach to this thing why did we even
do this so this is the this is the only
thing that has has as we're recording
this has been officially released but
I'm going to read it anyway
the boy raced through the woods blood
streaming from his hand he was growing
faint can't pass out just got to make it
to the fence he heard his pursuers
yelling they sounded as panicked as he
felt he didn't know if the dizziness was
due to blood loss or the shock of what
had just happened they were gonna kill
me he known this place was twisted from
day one when they'd stripped him of
everything including his own name but
even with all the vile things he'd seen
he is still assumed that the brutal
punishments were designed to intimidate
not exterminate that's why I've been so
calm willingly letting them guide him
along blindfolded and gagged right up
until the moment they'd sliced his palm
what if this particular test was no
different maybe he was doing exactly
what they wanted him to running through
the trees like a trophy animal they had
only cut his hand no arteries plus he'd
somehow gotten away from the two men
holding him one of them enormous much
bigger than any of the other adults he'd
seen there and they purposely let him go
no he shouldn't sell himself short he'd
fought like hell the boy felt the flash
of pride all those hours of memorizing
jean-claude Van Damme's moves had been
worth it
can't wait to rewatch kickboxer he
struggled to move at a full clip as
branches rocks and logs snuck up on him
in the sparse moonlight he dodged the
obstacles hoping he was heading in the
right direction where's the damn fence
he saw it just before he collided with
it the grass of the pasture on the other
side of the chain links glowing a dull
gray under the night sky he started to
climb without thinking pain exploding as
the metal wire slipped into his open
wound he stifled a scream hoping to
conceal his exact point of escape while
clinching his jaw summoning the resolve
to hoist himself up the ten-foot barrier
you saw it a cut section of fence not
five steps away lucky as he pushed his
way through the flap and stood in the
pasture he heard the roar of an engine
to his left a pickup truck was hurtling
across the pasture in his direction they
were trying to head him off he broke
into a sprint toward the cover of trees
bordering the pasture his shadow
sprawling in front of him as the
headlight shined on his back
he was confident in his speed 99th
percentile that President's Challenge
shuttle run he timed himself but they
were closing the distance fast get to
the tree line he knew there'd be a
barbed wire cow fence at the edge of the
field he'd have to clear it in stride in
only a matter of seconds they would be
upon him he was steps from the trees the
headlights lit up the short fence
helping him judge his distance he
stutter stepped to set up his leap and
threw his leg in the air a clean jump he
heard the truck skid to a stop on the
wet grass behind him the doors opening
men screaming he knew this stretch of
forest well there was barely a patch of
nature around town he hadn't explored
another hundred feet or so and he'd make
it to the clearing he broke into the
lane cut through the forest a grassy
corridor that followed the sewage line
along its lazy descent to the water
treatment plant he heard the chasers
clumsily moving through the woods
crashing into branches and crumbling to
themselves morons randomly choosing a
direction he dashed down the clearing
reaching a manhole in less than fifty
steps he grabbed a nearby stick and
jammed into the notch on the cover just
as he'd done a thousand times before no
longer thinking about his throbbing hand
the weighty metal disk lifted releasing
an acrid smell he raised the lid on his
edge and swiftly descended into the rank
darkness below skittering down the iron
rungs as fast as he could the disheveled
men popped out of the trees no more than
ten seconds after he dropped the manhole
cover in place the boy listened as
they're cursing voices past him he
waited in stinking silence for another
five minutes
thrusting opened the cover he emerged
into the damp air the boy fled deeper
into the woods
and we're off to the races the lost
causes a bleak Creek got a bleak Creek
calm or anywhere books are sold
yeah you know I don't want it this isn't
about like this isn't about an ad for
you to buy the book this is about a
celebration assuming that you're here
with us and it's you you want to read
the book so we're not trying to convince
you of anything but who was that boy hmm
was it you'll find out was it Rex was it
Leif
certainly wasn't read or link because
those characters aren't in the book true
I mean as you read through this thing is
there's so many things that jump out to
me that are from our childhood I think
just to take a stand we can talk about
some of those things for the prologue
but just to take a step back I think the
inception of the loss causes a bleak
Creek occurred in the wake of the
success of our coffee table slash memoir
slash advice book the book of
mythicality still available wherever
books are sold and our agent at the time
you know we were still having
conversations with him based on the
success of it and he just you know he
had a call with us and just pitched why
don't you guys would you guys ever
consider doing your version of a Hardy
Boys novel like think about young rhett
and Link in a fictional world and then
he sent covers of different covers of
Hardy Boys books and from like I guess
that's like the I was gonna say the 60s
I actually don't know it was a very long
stretch 60s included probably 50s
through 90s I don't know
so and you know the thing is is our
answer was yes a resounding yes sounds
very cool we have considered this
mmm-hmm yeah in fact we have talked for
years we have talked about you know how
do we bring out how do we take the
things that we kind of know about what
it was like growing up in the south as
some of the adventures that we went on
and how do we translate that into
something creative we've always assumed
that that would be a film I you know I
think that's how we've talked about it's
like right we're working on all this
stuff but we're kind of working up to
this place where we're gonna make
something that you know the south is a
character and it's got kids who are
friends and they're dealing with
something and we've kind of slowly been
working and we've got like loose
concepts that kind of float
but we had not ever considered well
maybe you should start with a novel and
it wasn't until Mark our agent at the
time basically was like he said exactly
what link said and that was when we're
like oh this is a way to actually get
the ball rolling on this idea and maybe
this is actually the perfect answer to
that yeah and then when we started to
talk about the specifics like pulling
together all of the previous
conversations that you just mentioned
that we had had over the years it it
very quickly gained momentum that yeah
this can be this can be about us as kids
basically and then we started to pitch
that and it it gained momentum and it
very very quickly I'd say almost
immediately we knew that we weren't
going to make another version of the
Hardy Boys I was a Hardy Boys fan
growing up but then yeah like a big
choose-your-own-adventure fan as well
but it was that's for younger kids
younger kids and there's a kind of they
can meanness to it and this is and we
were like we want to make a book that's
got humor in it of course but we we want
this to be sincerely dramatic and
thrilling and scary and dark along with
that humor and also and for any trace of
her target audience
something that we would want to read so
this is not a children's book no but you
know there's been lots of talk of like
is this is this an adult book is this a
young adult book Hey all we can say is
that it's a lot like what we do
with everything else we do it's kind of
for everybody I mean sure I mean like
Shepard asked me can I read out I was
like yeah I mean it's got some stuff in
there that is a little off-color and
might scare you a little bit but I you
know he can take it and then anybody who
is in high school right now I mean
because these characters are going into
high school it makes sense for for them
to read it and of course if you're like
us and you grew up in the 90s there's a
lot we go way beyond jean-claude Van
Damme's kickboxer and I think a lot of
lots of knives the other these
references yeah let's jump into the
specifics here the this boy who again
you'll you'll have to discover late
who that is if it's one of us or not
when he goes into the manhole at the end
it's like I have a specific vision like
I know the specific manhole because we
did this you know if you leave your
house and you go around the corner
there's of course they were there
there's sewage lines and manholes
everywhere and we might have jumped into
more than one but you know the one
particular one I'm thinking about but
behind at across the street from you go
around Adam Nicholson's well you go down
the street from Adam Nichols and it's
more like we're just and live just in
McCloud yeah and then you go downwards
like smaller than you get into yeah so
you get into the woods and there's like
these big corridors where the trees have
been removed and they put in the sewage
lines to get from one part of lake small
into Buies Creek and I assume that this
I assume that this exists in other towns
around the world but it was definitely
something that I mean the interesting
thing is that it didn't really exist
over near your house because there would
be like corridors for power lines but
there was something because there was a
water treatment plant I guess there
still is a water treatment plant that's
very close to Keith hills the country
club that I live outside of did not live
inside of but there were the these
corridors cut through the trees and it
was basically how we sort of mapped out
the woods that we played in and you
would also if you continued following
them you would get to places like we
talked about this in the book of
mythicality how we would followed one of
these for a really long time and took
some turns and ended up at Chris
Barefoot's house and we were like what
he lives over here and like it's just
connected and now I'm near the Harnett
County Airport and this is blowing my
mind but at one time we just went up to
a manhole and we took a stick or I I
kind of think we had to get a crowbar
but we learned how to do it with a stick
a lot of times in fact we didn't put
this in the in the documentary maybe
we'll make this like a special special
scene for the society or something but
we opened up a manhole right next to the
river using a stick because a lot of
times they didn't do it
them in quite right when they set them
back down so you can kind of get a stick
in there and kind of pry it open it
would be tough for a kid to do it by
himself but you know this is fiction
so we your hands cut but if you need to
get if you're running for your life he's
running first my adrenaline coming up
and so we pulled off the lid of a
manhole cover down in the woods beyond
Justin's house and then you crawl down
the ladder to the bottom and you just
sit there and it's like well it it's
Melda you some other waste of all your
neighbors and there's like an
accumulation of what sold refuse I'll
call it but it was it was wild it was
like man we're like feeling like a ninja
turtle it seemed like a portal to
another place I was really trying to
work in a ninja turtle reference at the
end of that but then it didn't happen it
didn't come together but there's an
there is a ninja turtle reference in the
book that's right it's just not right
there in the prologue well and I would
not recommend going down into the sewer
no no no don't do that the more twice I
would recommend doing it once everybody
needs to be able to say they've been
into don't pursue her don't go into
source with source especially oh gosh
you're skipped over a part that was also
an homage to something that happened to
us and that is the story we've told
several times about you you know we
would go to these pastures cow pastures
and we would run around chase cows and
then there would typically be like a
short barbed wire fence that had a
usually had like a line either in front
of it or right on top of it which was an
electrified fence and of course you'd
pee on it or you do whatever you touch
it and dare your friends I wouldn't
I've never peed on it are you so you're
talking about when I went over on this
thing yeah but so the idea of running
because what we did our story in real
life is running from a bull literally
when the bull turned on us and started
running at rest' and we me and you and
Ben ran and me and Ben got over the
fence and then of course you tried to go
to the fence and got stuck on the barbed
wire fence and
sea salt over it and then your leg came
up and caught the electrified fence and
then you began to get shocked in a
pulsing pattern which is how these
things which was funny to you but not to
me
right you were crying we were laughing I
wasn't crying a lot but I mean and you
were crying enough yeah and actually in
the documentary where we went back to
Buies Creek you can see the field in Lee
Creek conversations but you know what
let's get into some other excerpts and
reminisce on some other things but first
we want to let you know that along with
the release of the book we've got some
bleak Creek merch check it out at
mythical calm there's there's this
sweatshirt which is modeled after our
Buies Creek yellers because anything in
the in the book Bleak Creek High School
and bleak Creek middle school and
elementary school is all in the small
town of bleak Creek which is what it the
way it used to be back in the old days
of Buies Creek and these are the colors
and they were the demons and of course a
restaurant that we will get we get into
this yeah we're going to talk about
little Dino's which was the restaurant
of people that was in Buies Creek pizza
place the official ring T for little
Dino's and there's other stuff too
we're home a big Gary's we're all famous
kidney stones got a lost cause this
t-shirt we've got a pig pickin t-shirt
there's other things it's all over a
mythical calm mythical calm get your
bleak Creek merch and then the other if
you're listening
yeah well yeah November 4th we which did
it so be up it's confusing isn't it
right yeah ok let let's hit another
excerpt here
I must skip forward to chapter 10 but
but it kind of serves as an introduction
to the to the book if you haven't read
anything yet in some ways I just read do
this chapter 10 right at the top Rex and
Leif walked into the cafeteria on their
first day at bleak Creek High School
this moment had been building in Rex's
mind for years ever since his older
mr. misty told him that whoever you sat
with at lunch that first day could
determine your future Brad Stewart was
the smartest guy in eighth grade she
said but he sat with the Gardiner twins
his freshman year and now he drives an
ice cream truck
he Leif and Alicia had developed a plan
instead of buying lunch they would bring
their own to avoid the hiccup of having
to go through the line then they take
their own brown bags lunch boxes were
strictly off-limits sacrifice
particularly challenging for Leif
directly to the spot of their choice sit
down and wait to see who naturally
joined them the only rule they agreed on
was that Marc horn hat wasn't allowed an
initial scan of the room revealed that
nearly every table was already taken
with very few students in line buying
lunch maybe their plan wasn't so
original after all they walked around
methodically not talking wrecks doing
his best to play it cool and blend in
not an easy task considering he towered
over almost everyone while Leif somehow
forgot to move his arms as he walked
after two and a half laps around the
cafeteria Rex
looked at Leif and motioned with his
head toward a table next to them a
handful of guys and a girl they
recognized as upperclassmen were deep in
conversation but there were three open
seats mind if we sit here Rex asked huh
a blonde girl with a jean skirt asked go
for it stretch a guy with a vanilla ice
to the extreme t-shirt said before
turning back to jeans skirt and picking
up where they'd left off Thanks no
sooner had Rex and Leif sat down that
they got a powerful whiff of eternity
Marc horn hat appeared beside them as if
he'd been perched somewhere waiting for
them to decide on a table a very horn
hat move hey hey fellas he said taking
his lunch out of the backpack high
school is pretty rockin huh so many hot
babes Rex and Leif just stared at him
they both realized they stood a little
chance of rappelling horn hat freshmen
launch plan 1990
- was quickly falling apart oh man he
said what y'all did at that second
baptist fundraiser was so rad i can't
wait to see ghost dogs so i can relive
it does Boykins have launched this
period I want to congratulate her on her
performance especially the part at the
end Rex and lief continued staring
coming to grips with the fact that horn
hat might be a permanent fixture of
their cafeteria crew Rex new horn hats
dad was a doctor so at least eating with
him on a regular basis didn't guarantee
a future as an ice cream truck driver
first day of high school when we
conceptualize the the book we we knew
that we wanted sort of the added tension
and build-up that comes from the anxiety
associated with starting high school
right so that that happens you know this
that's it's the end of the summer of
1992 where these guys are getting ready
to go to high school and there's all
these apprehensions and of course III so
I have an older brother who when I was
his name is not misty his name is not
misty it's Cole and he was a senior when
I was a freshman and so a lot of the
perceptions that you have about high
school come from your older siblings who
kind of been down that path before of
course I didn't have one of those right
but you had Cole and me and then you
could so it was all filtered down so
this was not I can say I can safely say
this particular piece of advice about
who you sit with their first day at high
school is gonna determine a lot about
your future but I do believe in this
advice like I actually think that though
and this is the kind of thing you know I
told this to Locke when he was getting
ready to go to high school you probably
did all you did was make him nervous I
didn't tell him this specific thing like
who you sit with determines your future
it could be an ice cream truck driver
I've just said that the only thing I
said is the kind of people that you
surround yourself right will determine
your future but this is sort of the
pinpointed and I it's true because
we're creatures of habit and if you you
know you you stake your claim in the
cafeteria and unless you make an active
decision the passive thing that happens
is that's where you end up staying and
you know the group of friends are just
the people that are next to you are the
people that use you're literally rubbing
shoulders with and you know it's just it
just kind of goes from there so it
actually it it's a big moment well and
there is a principle at play like I
actually that name Brad Stewart that I
put together two names there Brad Inman
and yeah in Chris Stewart yeah and the
reason I did that is because those guys
were like Brad a man and Chris Stewart
were sort of the best of the best of
their classes right yeah and they and if
I don't Divac they were like hero heroes
of upper class I haven't kept up with
either of them but I have every reason
to believe that both of them went on to
become successful at whatever they
endeavored and they did not become ice
cream truck drivers I will say that
safely and I and this person is not
based on them legally I need to say that
it's just I in honor of those two guys I
took those two names of eating together
but it was what if there was a guy who
was this in eighth grade he was this
person that everybody knew was gonna be
super successful but he made he made the
choice to sit with the wrong people it
became an ice-cream truck driver that
was just a very fun thing to play with
it does happen you too could be an ice
cream truck driver and you know what
there's no shame in that
okay well you're talking out of both
sides I'm mad listen to stay firm man
okay I mean some people are ice cream
truck drivers and some people live in
the neighborhoods where the ice cream
trucks come I don't know is not a good
leave it but we I mean as we reminisced
and we've done that a lot on and off
your biscuits on and off the internet
for over a decade we often come back to
them to the all the expectations
associated with headed into high school
you know it's like we've spoken before
about
the girls that we had heard their names
or just seen them at at rival when you
played rival basketball teams in middle
school like one person had gone to a
different pool for a day yes we talked
about all that they knew the girls at
the other pool we really got excited
about that moment you know and then of
course you know from from a practical
planning standpoint it kind of gives you
a bit of a runway if if you you know if
you want the story to continue beyond
just one book if you know what I'm
saying oh yeah I know what you're saying
and I you know but when it comes to the
cafeteria I do remember one story that I
may have told before but it's been quite
a while but I remember it it wasn't the
first day of school but you remember one
where we sat and I'm it had to have been
our freshman year because Eric Hauck was
a seniors right when you walk in or walk
out on the left so man Erica she was she
was notable yes you are a number of
reasons
popular girl yeah and if you access when
we told the story before I've I may have
since heard it more than all sensor here
but I remember I we knew where she you
know she was a senior she was she was
she was fun to look at as a freshman I'm
just gonna you know she wore very very
specifically bright pink lipstick and
she had jet black hair but then she dyed
it blonde and there was like an ombre
thing going on which you might just say
okay she let her roots grow out but
there was something it was it did a lot
for us that's all I'll say
as a as a 1992 boy from Buies Creek it
did a lot for me yeah and I'm you know
not to mention the cleavage yeah she was
not bashful no I mean we knew where she
lived and you in you know you could get
you could get to Andrew by driving on 55
or you could you know you could you
could take this little shortcut which
yeah it took a little bit longer but
let's take this shortcut so we can go in
front of Erica tell us because well she
would sit on her she would put out a
beach chair and she would sunbathe in
her
lon wouldn't you yeah so uh you know we
attended to fixate on her a little bit
and where when I think she knew that
where we sat in the cafeteria she would
when she would get her tray she walked
by mm-hmm and man I can't I can't
remember exactly what what led her to
say something
yeah I've haven't written it part of the
story I can't remember but but you know
because we've been on the internet long
enough
I could probably access an earlier
version of this story and figure out why
what what led her to see what she said
but I will never forget what she said
she said let's think about yeah because
I said something to her
I think we there was a dare will you say
something to Erica that's what it was
and you did is I never spoken to her and
I think it was like I like something you
said something I can't remember what it
was man can't remember that part of the
story but I took the Dare and I did say
something to her I believe as she walked
by and she turned to me and said is your
little heart and I said in my memory I
said no but my big kiss I probably
didn't say that I probably didn't say
that I know you know what I think you
could let's just change the story I
definitely said no but my big yes right
that's that's the only way to come back
to that yeah when I ever I think of the
cafeteria at our high school I always
remember that moment I don't remember
anything around it apparently it's like
what led up to it but I do remember that
and it was embarrassing
yeah but thrilling so we didn't put that
scene in the book because that would
have been a little distracting but
here's something else we did put and
sorry Erica and this ties in with
shouldn't have been like that am I going
to the right place now I'm going to
Janine yep yeah let's let's introduce
the character Janine big Gary again this
all happens a little Dino's the t-shirt
I'm wearing
big Gary's kidney stones weren't as
vomit-inducing as Janine had been a
Burma lips on with oregano oil so I
because I was getting a sore throat I
put oregano oil and salt in hot and warm
water and I gargle with it but it kind
of burns it kills things but it burned
my lips your breath probably smells like
little dinos this was like two days ago
and my lips are still I actually just
put some of your peculiarly perfect
peppermint peanut butter peppermint lip
balm on my lips to try to soothe them
it's working but it's like it's
affecting my speech big Gary's kidney
stones weren't as vomit-inducing as
Janina had been expecting in fact if she
hadn't already known what she was
staring at she might have mistaken it
for a jar of pebbles something she would
have kept on the Shelf in her bedroom
during her collecting pointless things
face now don't forget this side big gary
said turning the jar so Janine and her
camcorder could capture every cubic inch
of kidney stone while the colossal man
wore nearly constant broad smile his
eyes betrayed the baseline level of
skepticism he reserved for anyone from
outside of Harlan County
great Janine said her eye pressed to the
lens zero emotion in her voice really
great they were standing in the back of
little Dino's pizza and subs Donna
behind them already immersed in the
process of washing dishes big Gary had a
habit of filling any gaps in
conversation with a series of gentle but
guttural noises almost like he was
tasting something he liked the volume
and frequency of these sounds increased
as Janine racked focus across the jar as
she stood there pointing her camcorder
to grown man's rock collection birthed
from his own urethra listening to him
say hmm-hmm over and over again she
couldn't ignore the voice in her head
screaming this is why he went to grad
school this is why you're thousands of
dollars in debt so you could do this
I've been waiting so long for someone to
film these big Gary said staring at the
jar with pride resisting the urge to say
seriously Janeane zoomed
out to capture big Gary and his booger
green little Dino's polo shirt in all
its glory she couldn't imagine any color
looking worse on camera that's why I
keep them displayed on the counter out
there
this jar big Gary held it as close to
the camera lens as possible
filling up the frame with a blurred
nothingness is a symbol of all the pain
I went through shows how tough I am you
know that expression look at the stones
on that one but gary paused as if he
were waiting for Janine to answer that's
actually the bumper sticker on my car
she said calculating that big Gary
wouldn't detect her sarcasm well then
alright big Gary said so you know what
I'm getting at look at the stones on
this one my stones Jeannine couldn't
help but smile though not for the
reasons big Gary thought she turned to
see if Donna was smiling too but nope
she was sliding a rack of glasses into
the industrial dishwasher and pushing it
closed initiating a loud splashing and
humming so tell me big Gary said
speaking louder to compete with the
running dishwasher is this gonna be like
in the movie theaters and whatnot
definitely Janine said doing her best to
wipe the smile off her face as she
lowered the camera Wow big Gary said
nodding excitingly and releasing a
barrage of moves Roger hums so that's
that's uh that's big Gary and that's
Janine at little Dino's yeah Janine is
another key character you know this the
book isn't just about Rex and leaf and
following their adventures but there's a
an adult character as well Janine and
I'm not gonna say anything beyond what
was revealed in this passage but she as
you can see she went to film school I'm
a big fan of Janine she's um she's got
this she always knows what to say like
she can be a smartass she you know she's
I I enjoy the way that she like forms a
connection with Rex and leaf that's kind
of interesting you know it's like they
much like us they're aspiring filmmakers
so it's like there was respect
and grounds for that connection which
which proves to be very necessary with
what they need to accomplish right what
and the whole idea of putting of kidney
stones being featured in this chapter
and a lot of kidney stones you if you
read the book you'll understand what
that's about but and this was actually
sort of a central point it was one of
the as we were piecing together the
story and kind of coming up with what
exactly is going on in bleak Creek
kidney stones is actually was it was a
kind of a starting point so it's
interesting that it's a starting point
for Janine and what she's trying to
accomplish now you never had a kidney
stone I have it but I'm I've never had a
kid I am I am fascinated and obsessed
needed by and obsessed with them because
I you know I feel like I have a tendency
to get I mean this might just be in my
mind I feel like I get weird I get weird
things like you know I've got herniated
discs I've got psoriasis and I had that
thing happened with my eye and you know
I was a chronic nose bleeder growing up
and I'm a pretty I'm you know I'm not
like a sickly person but I feel like I
have like these you know weird not
life-threatening but annoying maladies
so you feel primed to get a kidney stone
but you think yours would be shaped like
a ninja star
well not that my brother has had them
ninja star he said he's had kidney
stones and you know they say bring it to
your knees the conventional wisdom of
the kidney stone is that it is the only
thing that is comparable to a woman
giving birth that a man can experience
and my brother can attest to that
basically it's hell on earth it's hell
in your and it's not really you always
think oh this must be this must hurt
when it's coming out your ding-a-ling
and that's and that's the part that's
not that's not the part that hurts
coming out your dingaling is the fun
part it's really it's when it begins it
discs it gets dislodged from your
kidney yeah when it basically moves and
begins to work its way down to your
ding-a-ling through the urethra as we
said no the urethra I think is from the
bladder it's got to get to the bladder
so it's the process of getting from the
kidney to the bladder which there's I'm
sure there's a name for that tube it's
not the urethra as far as I know and
that process and what most men or women
who have this happen to them to think is
oh I like I pulled a muscle like I
pulled a muscle I'm having a really bad
back day and because I've got lower back
issues already every time I feel
something and it's a little bit
different I'm just like oh I know I'm
gonna get kidney stones now because Cole
got him and it's just a matter of time
before I get him my dad had one and it
was it was so big because they say well
the best thing to do is just to pass it
and they want you to catch it so they
can analyze it for some reason but
that's also fun as well yeah I guess you
get a special basket but give you a
lollipop if you take a guinea stone into
the doctor's office which but it's
kidneys don't flavor it don't don't get
your hopes up but that depends on what
you ate somebody's ate a lot of
lollipops a lot of tea you drink a lot
of tea it's a team kidney stones taste
like tea I mean you could you could open
up that jar and taste one of big Gary's
I'm sure he wasn't looking put sprinkle
them on your pizza like that
Red's red stuff you put on pizza at the
table I think they're just made out of
like calcium and my dad's was so big
that they had to go in you can go up in
there and then they grabbed it and
crushed it out and in my mine Annie I
remember when I was a kid she had a she
went in and she came out from a
procedure and she had a t-shirt and I
said I've been lit the trips lit the
trip seed that's a t-shirt you can get
lit the trip C is when they blast sound
waves yeah at your at your kidney and
and break up a kidney stone to make it
smaller so it can pass and they'll and
for some reason though only stones are
candidates for that like my brother I
don't think has had that done I think
he's just had to pass he's had a lot
though he said I don't know maybe three
four I don't know
big Barry's had a jarful
and there is a so as we were trying to
figure out like how many kidney stones
are too many because it unfolds why
there's kidney stones and what people
are getting them what big Gary has them
and why there's so many the world record
for kidney stones is actually there's
somebody who passed I don't remember
what it was but the numbers of kidney
stones that we put into the book we're
based on looking up what's the
reasonable amount here like looks like a
maximum amount of kidney stones this is
a year it's not a ridiculous amount it's
there are some people who can form them
that quickly depending on the conditions
that's got to be a nightmare I don't
want to ever experience that let's read
another excerpt oh but lil Dino's was an
actual place yeah in Buies Creek it was
the only restaurant in town I it wasn't
that great I actually don't remember
ever eating there we also didn't spend a
lot of we didn't like spend money on
food you know we ate at home and it
wasn't like hey mom give me five dollars
I want to go get pizza is it my turn to
read it is yeah
Rex now turned into a gravel driveway
the small wheels of a scooter grinding
to a crunchy stop on the loose rocks
that led to the house of Travis Bethune
not only was Travis the nicest person
Rex and leaf had ever met seemingly
never disparaging anyone but he had an
untold number of jobs landscaper septic
tank pumper chimney sweep house painter
and most important volunteer fireman he
traveled from job to job on his bright
red moped and wore a thick black leather
belt that held a walkie-talkie to
beepers a flashlight a large bowie knife
and a giant keyring loaded with what
looked to be 30 keys or more the
teenagers around bleak creek regularly
referred to him as redneck batman he
didn't seem to mind the moniker and Rex
and lief didn't know if that was due to
his unwavering positivity or just the
general allure of being compared to
Batman suffice it to say when Rex
realized he needed a fire extinguisher
he immediately thought of Travis who'd
called Rex back three minutes after he
beeped him Rex walked the rest of the
way up to the single wide trailer which
Travis referred to as his ranch-style
house
despite the wheels under the mobile home
being only somewhat obscured by the wood
lattice skirting Travis opened the door
before Rex even reached the front steps
hey man
he said flashing his signature grin come
on in my casa
your casa Rex didn't often see Travis
without his utility belt he seemed
smaller thanks Travis Rex said hit with
the smell of solder wire and bacon
grease as he stepped onto the brown shag
carpet he'd only been to Travis's house
once before as he always seemed to be
out and about glad you're here
Travis said adopting a serious tone he
added you know I ain't supposed to share
the tools of the trade with a layman
like yourself but I'm willing to make an
exception for you now what do you need
it for again for Poulter dog Travis
asked no a new project it's a kind of
experimental you mean like about
chemistry or something
Rex felt horrible lying to Travis but it
was just too easy and necessary sorta
yeah you boys are so dang creative a
chemistry movie that sounds awesome
yep you sure you don't want me to come
and keep an eye on things when you do
the pyro Travis asked I live for that
kind of stuff he leaned in and spoke in
a whisper to tell you the truth that's
why I'm a volunteer fireman I love to
watch stuff burn catching himself he
said loudly of course I love putting it
out too well I don't think he'd find
this too interesting
just sparklers rec said adding another
thread to his web of white lies hmm yeah
that ain't really even fire
Travis paused looking at the fake wood
paneled wall all right let me get it
drivers got up and walked through a bead
curtain to the back of his trailer
Rex stood waiting surveying Travis's
assortment of what looked to be about a
hundred California Raisins figurines on
the kitchen counter there are lots of
repeats at least 20 of the one on the
skateboard they're cool as hell huh
Travis said returning with an ancient
looking fire extinguisher yeah pretty
cool Rex said smartest thing Hardy's
ever did
I wish they'd bring him back he said
shaking his head anyway
here she is he extended the fire
extinguisher to Rex
thanks Travis I really appreciate this
Rex ed my pleasure buddy Travis Bethune
is one of my favorite supporting
characters in the cast he's the type of
guy that we feel like we've known
forever it's like a very Harnick county
type guy it wasn't based on one
particular person there's a lot of
people like this there's a lot of people
who just have a lot of equipment on them
on a belt on their person a tone and do
a lot of different things and you can't
point to the one job that they do
because they do a multitude of jobs so
he's kind of a composite character in
that way and also I do think that the
reference to thinking of your trailer as
a as a branch home I didn't ever hear
anyone say that but it just that struck
me is a very got the impression a very
funny thing something they could have
thought because what because you know
there's different styles of trailers
there's different levels sure you got
some trailers that are just like I'm not
trying to disguise like it's obvious
like we don't have any skirting on this
we could hook a truck up to it and
immediately get out of here if we needed
to
yeah but then there isn't one so they
they don't unhook the truck but then
there are the ones that are established
the wheels haven't moved in years
they've planted like a small garden
around the trailer and it begins that
you begin to be lulled into the
impression that this is just somebody's
ranch-style home okay there might be a
foundation under there I thinking about
Travis's fixation on things
earning that was that was based on the
true story or maybe not maybe we don't
want to be too incriminating but we're
not gonna I'm not gonna say who it was
but we were told there was a rumor that
went around town and I believe he was at
some point prosecuted for this but there
was a rumor that a person who was on the
volunteer fire department was always the
first to the scene in the fire and it
turns out he was setting homes on fire
but not occupied homes like laying
abandoned homes they go up quick yeah I
get here so quickly
my my ex stepdad Jimmy was also a
volunteer fireman and my next-door
neighbor Pete Dinklage was and in the
middle of church sometimes like the
pastor will be given a sermon and then
you could hear across town the siren go
off for the volunteer fire they didn't
use beepers they just had a giant he
actually had a beeper too but but they
use a giant siren that could be heard
throughout the entire town of Buies
Creek and if the preacher would be
preaching and then all of a sudden Jimmy
would get up and run out of the back of
the sanctuary and I thought that was
cool super cool cool as hell one might
say right which is another saying that
we we took from somebody specifically
but you know what let's just read
another excerpt yeah I was just quick
shout out to the California Raisins
though because California Raisins were a
big part of our childhood we both
collected them I'm sure you collect it
more than I did but I had the full set
in my bedroom oh you know I had the full
and there was there they released them
so this is one of those things where
when you're writing a book that takes
place in 1992 like we actually went to
pretty great lengths to make sure that
the timing of everything is working out
like okay were they out by then and were
they still out so the reason that Travis
says coolest you know cool as hell and
the best thing Hardy's ever did I wish
they'd bring him back is because in 1992
they were not out they had been taken
off the Hardys wasn't doing that but
Hardee's did bring them back later and
then I think again but this was in one
of the California raisin list times of
Hardee's yeah is when the book takes
place come on get that right before it
in my trumpet case my trumpet that I
play when we do when we do shows I still
have my California reins raisins trumpet
player inside of that case because from
seventh grade okay we're gonna divide
this one up oh this is the conversation
from chapter 13 between Rex and Leafs
and so we might as well just read it as
Rex and leave obviously Rex this may be
okay about that okay this may be
familiar to you if you know of if you've
been watching Vidar videos for a long
time as they crouched in silence
watching and waiting they noticed the
cicadas belting out their pulsing songs
around them making the forest seem alive
like I had a giant beating heart I'm
kind of hungry Leif said terror and
hunger were often interchangeable for
him here Rex dug around in his backpack
and chucked a huge ziplock bag over to
Leif brought some trail mix Thanks
Leif said instantly comforted by a
familiar snack you can have some too
been reck said I'm okay been said still
pretty full for my three squirrel dinner
alright Rex said as he noticed Leif
taking out individual peanuts from the
bag and consuming them one by one he was
tempted to say something but he was well
acquainted with Leafs pickiness his
aversion to olives mushrooms and
pepperoni had sabotage many a pizza
order in either way this was no time to
bicker over trail mix etiquette then
Leif popped another peanut in his mouth
chewing so loudly the sound began to
rival the cicadas hey Leif don't let's
not let's not do it like that
like what Leif asked like eating all the
peanuts and nothing else but I don't
like M&Ms of raisins I'm avoiding them
yep but you're throwing off the whole
ratio my mom had a specific mix in mind
you think your mom is gonna be upset
about me eating the peanuts no Rex said
growing more flustered but when you eat
trail mix you're supposed to take a
handful everybody knows that what you
get is what you eat
maybe quiet down a bit been said from
between them
sorry Rex ed yeah Leif said depositing
yet another peanut under his tongue you
offer me a snack and then you're telling
me how to eat it makes it kind of hard
to enjoy okay
Rex said reaching his arm across been
give me back my mom's trail mix no leaf
said holding the bag close you he didn't
finish his sentence because that's when
the chanting started oh crap the chance
what so you know in the if you looked at
if you looked at the videos as a weird
way to say if you watched our romantical
roadtrip 2011 our trip from there's my
Carolina to California there's one
called trail mix so you can check that
out traffic sand argument that's the
that's the original inception of of this
particular exchange yes which we that we
had it we had in real life in that video
and we had versions of it in row we've
had that conversation multiple times and
again every time I eat your trail mix so
you you already know that Rex and Lee
for very very much based on rhett and
Link and but they're different in a lot
of ways as I like pepperoni that we made
that we made them wrecks it and leaf but
but you prefer sausage you don't that's
true so I've tried to get pepperoni many
times and you that you and I put this
don't like M&Ms and my trail mix about
those exact things in there because you
have sabotage many a pizza order in real
life that's all I'm gonna say and we
didn't we didn't talk about you not
liking tomatoes in this passage that
happens in another passage yeah and the
little Dino's seen so again there's a
lot of us that personally informs these
characters in a way that we interact
with each other at the way that we have
interacted with each other throughout
our entire lives and the way we continue
to interact with each other is the way
that you'll see Rex and Leif interact
with each other and and I think that
that was the most fun aspect of this for
me is the fact that we get to pull on
the things that are actually true about
us and we're true about us but then take
them to completely crazy places because
we're writing a novel this is a fiction
this is a fictional exercise and
speaking of crazy places that's when the
chanting began is you know the dot dot
dot
into a crazy place and you know the
excerpts that we chose were more about
introducing you to some of the
characters and you know helping convey
the humor and the setting and just kind
of the the more light-hearted tone to
the lost causes of bleak Creek but
suffice it to say there's a lot of
darkness and we can't read any of that
without giving away write too much the
pages are the same color throughout but
if I worked but if we were to track them
we could have put a gradient because as
you go that would be it gets difficult
printing exercise when we make a
gradient across the pages so it's all
dark by the end and you can't read it
and it flips over for to white text on
black somewhere it's just gray on gray
and you can't do anything that's the
mistress a good idea that's why it's
called a mystery novel because you don't
know what the middle is yeah that's I
mean it it gets real it does and it gets
very serious I hope you get scared I
just can't wait to start hearing from
your experience as a reader
hashtag bleak Creek please let us know
well and I would say I think that's
something that's something I'm very
excited about you've listened this far
you probably either have already bought
the book or you're planning on buying
the book but and I'm sure we're gonna
say this again we understand and there's
a little bit of a chip on our shoulder
with everything that we do because in in
today's world and 2019 where you've got
anybody can be a youtuber really it
doesn't you can call yourself a youtuber
all you got to do is have a camera make
videos from your bedroom there's a very
there's a speaking of a gradient there's
a large gradient between you know we're
doing this for a living right we've been
doing it for a living for a long time
but you trying to say we're awesome no
I'm just saying we're never going to
shake the perception that comes along
with being a youtuber and I understand
that I rose that come along with someone
who is a youtuber who's only gotten
famous because they make videos that
anyone can upload to the Internet then
decides to write a novel
and like I said if you listen this far
you don't need to be convinced about
this
you were like oh this they're passionate
about this I'm sure that it's gonna
enjoy it whatever but just so you know
because I think we're all a team here
the mythical beast kind of working
together for whatever we're going for
mythical world domination it's very
important that this book gets beyond the
mythical herd you know I think that for
anyone who enjoys this genre mystery
thriller horror but also comedy mixed in
and also time period based thing in the
90s any there's a lot of touch points
for this and it we really just want it
to connect with people who may have just
concluded oh those are the guys that eat
goat testicles on the internet why the
hell would I care about a book that they
wrote trust me I understand that
sentiment but I think that too obviously
we're trying to get the message out that
this is something that we feel is a is a
book that can really capture your
interest and keep your interest and
whether you know us or not so we would
just ask like link was saying you know
if you've got a copy for yourself share
it with somebody else buy a copy for
somebody else buy a copy for somebody
for Christmas somebody who if they if
you know they would have a problem
knowing that it's coming from a youtuber
who eats goat testicle take the cover
off take the cover off and don't tell
them who rub mclaughlin and link Neal
are take this part off because we think
this story stands on itself and we
stands on its own and we stand on itself
it stands on itself and on its own
school and we don't think that it needs
to be accompanied by hey we got to show
that a lot of people watch and that's
what people are gonna buy this book
that's not what it's about for us this
is an artistic Enterprise yet we're very
very passionate about did you get the
chip off your shoulder no the chip will
always be there is your little card and
hash tag bleak creek thank you for
taking Reds advice into consideration
speaking of advice do you have I have a
recommendation it's a book called no I'm
not gonna do that you thought I was
gonna do that you thought my reckon
effect was gonna be the lost causes of
bleak
rique well I really want it to be but
I'm gonna give you another wreck I'm
gonna don't make it another book I'm
gonna give a musical wreck and maybe
this is a this is music that you can
listen to while you're enjoying the loss
causes the Bleak Creek I'll put this on
my Spotify it's probably already on your
Spotify Whitney Whitney Houston now no
you should listen to Whitney Houston no
not Whitney Houston but there's a band
that's called Whitney it's not a person
named Whitney it's just some dudes who
call themselves Whitney and if you're
not careful and you say you know tell
Spotify to play Whitney sometimes
they'll just play Whitney Houston so he
have say Whitney the band I'm going to
recommend a specific song which is is it
forever what's the name of their last
album forever or ever turned around so
forever turned around first of all I
think you can just shuffle play these
guys and and they're singing in this
falsetto and it's this very it's just a
groove and it's just very much chill
music but if you're gonna listen to one
song as an introduction to Whitney I
suggest forever turned around which is
the title track from there 2019 album
which I guess is their latest album
forever turned around Whitney check them
out listen to it as you're enjoying the
lost causes of Donna to Julian and Max
in the meantime I'll be aggressively
knocking trying to knock off the chip on
my shoulder with your help well speak at
you next week to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best